[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
thank you thank you because I needed
that because I we all had a rough week I
feel like Nancy Pelosi's copy of the
State of the Union I am I am all torn up
I tell you I but look I can't get around
this was Trump's best week ever
I mean acquitted State of the Union he
walked in all the Republicans were
chanting USA USA to remind him of the
country he works for but yeah it
happened this week no more rules Trump
was acquitted by the Senate the
Republicans got together and I said this
was just too important not to get wrong
one dissenting vote and it drove them
[ __ ] crazy
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney the constant
searching for some Republican Savior but
no mitt was pretty good he said I don't
need to worship Trump I'm already in a
cult
but yeah this how you know you're guilty
president when a guy who believes in
magic underwear and that Jesus Jesus
lived in Branson Missouri and that you
get your own planet when you die goes
boy that was some [ __ ] so MIT is MIT
is being banished from the Republican
Party he's a traitor he is a heretic he
is a suppressive person no it's the
other culture now we are living in the
age of revenge today john bolton
disappeared and his mustache came up in
the mail
i'm just saying if you see Trump on
Fifth Avenue with a gun walk the other
way he can pretty much do no Trump boy
he was mango man mango Unchained now he
yesterday yesterday was the scariest day
of ever up with him Brenton there's been
a lot but he called in all the members
of his extended crime family for this
unhinged victory speech to just see this
and whenever he starts bragging you know
he winds up just incriminating himself
he said had I not fired James Comey we
would I wouldn't be standing here now
course because he's a cop and you're a
crook exactly and then before that he
was at a prayer breakfast Nancy Pelosi
was there and he said I don't like
people who say I pray for you because
you know she always says I pray for you
well I'm kind of what about that would a
theist get that a lot I get that a lot I
pray for you I always say thank you I'll
sin for you
hey let's not get down too much there is
good news and arctica is 65 degrees
right now which means we're all gonna
die look no really
65 degrees in Antarctica it was colder
this morning than Beverly Hills
the world is so upside down right I was
driving into work I saw a polar bear
with fake tits
oh speaking of fake tits it's the Oscars
on Sunday come on oh it's our it's our
big day out here in Los Angeles when the
most fabulous successful people get just
a little more it's our version of a
Republican tax cut I think
and I tell you the red carpet has really
changed in the last two years now the
big question is who are you accusing
but I am looking forward to the Oscars I
must say as a kind of a diversion from
this week and everything that's going on
I'm just glad that the voting wasn't
handled at the Oscars by the Democratic
Party in Iowa would you like and the
winner is we'll let you know Thursday we
saw that what went on in Iowa boy
Democrats ready on day one to trip over
their own dick you know not everything
needs a nap they were [ __ ] up the
voting Democrats have this great idea
let's give brand-new technology to a
bunch of 90 year olds voting in a barn
potin was like we're working too hard no
I think the lesson there is if you want
technology that connects people in Iowa
stick to farmers only
you